make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another installment
of our beyond omega level series where
we discuss the most powerful characters
in comics and for this episode we're
focusing on one of the most powerful and
most prominent villains of the dc
universe
true form darkseid now darkseid was
created by jack kirby and first appeared
in forever people number one
in 1971 darkseid was originally known as
prince yuxas the son of king yukikon
and queen hegra of apocalypse a planet
that's completely covered by one hellish
city now yugicon is able to wield the
omega force an extremely powerful energy
source and one of his son's drax tries
to gain access to the omega force but
before he can he's murdered by his
brother yuxas and so exposure to the
omega force drastically transforms
yuxa's appearance and he begins using
the moniker of darkseid
not satisfied with killing only one
family member darkseid follows up his
brother's murder by ordering the murder
of his mother hegra who'd arranged to
have darkseid's wife killed as she
thought she was a bad influence on her
son now upon his mother's death darkseid
ascends to the throne of apocalypse
which he rules in a brutal tyrannical
fashion
as he strives to win the constantly
ongoing war with new genesis now if
apocalypse was jack kirby's version of
hell then new genesis
was its heavenly counterpart and was
home to a race of divine beings called
the new gods but it's always being
attacked by darkseid's forces
eventually darkseid's ambitions would
extend beyond new genesis and he would
try and invade earth as well which would
put him at odds with the justice league
and superman in particular now this was
the version of darkseid's origin that
remain
in place from the time he was introduced
until dc's reboot with the new 52 line
in 2011. now in the new 52 continuity
uxas was not a prince
but a farmer fed up with laboring just
to survive yuxas decides the gods must
not care about ordinary people and
devises a plan to get revenge on them
and so while the god slept
yuxas climbed the mountain where they
live and whispers doubts into their ears
prompting them to go to war with one
another and so when the gods weaken from
battle uxas kills each of them in turn
stealing their power and becoming
darkseid the first of the new gods he
then proceeds to destroy his homeworld
and create apocalypse in its place
now as a member of the new gods darkseid
is both immortal and extremely powerful
darkseid is a being of nearly
immeasurable strength and was able to
crush
an extremely durable green lantern ring
with his bare hands
his punches are strong enough to deal
significant damage to some of the
strongest heroes in dc comics such as
superman
captain atom and eclipso who's an entity
on par with the specter so being able to
harm him is a pretty big deal
furthermore darkseid is nearly
invulnerable having been completely
unphased by a blast that was said to be
strong enough to kill any living thing
as well as an explosion that was
supposedly able to destroy everything in
existence
darkseid's most potent attacks are
derived from his ability to wield the
omega effect which is a vast source of
cosmic energy the dark side uses in
various ways
the most common way we see darkseid
utilize the omega effect
is in the form of the devastating omega
beans these beams can generate enough
concussive force to knock out monel
and supergirl and harm superman and even
the specter now once a target is hit
with the omega beams it's nearly
impossible for them to escape
unless darkseid wants them to and even
superman was unable to escape them
additionally
darkseid can use the beams to literally
remove his opponents from existence
if he chooses to dartside can also use
the omega sanction which he uses to trap
a victim in an
endless stream of lives that gets
excessively worse so the person trapped
in the omega sanction
lives out a life dies and is born again
into a new more hopeless life and this
cycle repeats itself for eternity
with no chance of escape now another
aspect of darkseid's power is his vast
telepathic ability which has been shown
to be stronger than those of martian
manhunter who's considered to be one of
dc's strongest telepaths
not only was darkseid able to
telepathically control martian manhunter
but he was also able to mentally control
a planet's entire population which
measured at around 3 billion
individuals and darkseid also possesses
telekinesis can teleport to any point in
the universe instantaneously
and is able to manipulate the time
stream even more impressively darkseid
is able to manipulate matter and was
able to create a starship
larger than the state of new york using
only a fraction of his power and is also
proven to be able to resurrect the dead
with very little effort
additionally darkseid is incredibly
intelligent and has access to incredibly
advanced technology
far beyond that which exists on earth
and its tyrannical rule of apocalypse
has resulted in countless hordes of
blindly loyal minions that serve
darkseid's every command
without hesitation and so with all that
being said it's clear that darkseid is
one of the most powerful villains in the
dc universe he's easily capable of
destroying planets we saw him do just
that in the new 52 origin story right
before he created apocalypse and i think
that sometimes fans don't really get an
accurate idea of how powerful darkseid
is
because of one particular individual
superman if we think about it logically
darkseid is vastly more powerful than
superman and we've seen him just
casually smack superman around on
several occasions when one punch sent
superman
into the source wall and trapped him
there temporarily furthermore
he has proven to be stronger than other
kryptonians like supergirl and was much
stronger than monel who belongs to the
daxomite race which are very similar to
kryptonians in the sense that he punched
him into a coma and so if we're being
objective
in our analysis darkseid should defeat
superman anytime they cross paths but of
course that doesn't happen because
superman's a good guy and at the end of
the day superhero comic books exist for
the good guy to overcome the odds and
seemingly defeat
unbeatable villains and like i said the
funny thing about this
is that all these power feats all these
feats that we've listed here right
all the things that we've that we've
shown that dark side can do this is an
avatar
this is a a copy of dark side that he
sends to himself that's why we're
calling this true form dark side because
every single this this is where things
kind of get meta-textual and it gets a
little bonkers
all of every single instance that you've
seen of darkseid
in dc comics is just a facsimile of
himself
it's it's dark side creating more or
less an avatar and
sending that avatar forward and then
having that avatar do a particular thing
right
invade earth during the new 52 justice
league during the the first story arc
you know or i don't know like face off
against the anti-monitor or something
like that
true form dark side is its dark side on
a meta textual level it's dark side as a
concept and the reason why is because
darkseid represents ultimate evil
he represents this the the concept of
evil and so long as there are sentient
beings that exists anywhere in the
multiverse there will be good and there
will be evil right that's why like high
father is kind of like that that you
know there's true form high father
that's that's one of the things that
made darkseid so crazy when darkseid
quote unquote you know basically won and
he defeated high father uh then in
effect
evil began to overtake goodness because
there really wasn't any goodness anymore
and so
all the different heroes started losing
to all the villains regardless of how
powerful they were right because the the
true male true form dark side had
defeated true form
uh high father and that basically led to
evil winning over good
in every single form right so again it's
a concept it's an ideology true form
darkseid could
never truly be defeated and aside from a
high father there's no one out there
that could successfully defeat him
because high father you know true form
high father is the true antithesis
to true form darkseid right so only
absolute good
can defeat absolute evil and superman is
not that so that's why when people make
arguments and they say things like well
you know doomsday
defeated darkseid doomsday defeated a
facsimile of darkseid right he did he
defeated
a a copy of darkseid there was nowhere
near as powerful as his true form if you
want to get
you want to know more about true form
darkside go check out grant morrison's
final crisis it's a little bit crazy and
it's grant morrison being grant morrison
right like nobody understands what grant
morrison means when he creates stuff
grant morrison fans will tell you they
do but they don't they probably had to
read the story like five or six times in
order to begin to understand
what he was talking about grant
morrison's crazy right that's really all
it comes down to
but on this he was right right that's
that's one of the the cool things there
so yeah
true form darkseid with all the stuff
that we've seen here in terms of like
the actual
feats he's accomplished over the course
of dc comics these are avatars these are
facsimiles as
impressive as these are none of these
compare to what true form dark side can
actually do
which is in effect anything and
everything the only reason why i didn't
really cover that is because it'd be
like a 30 second video right
beyond omega level true form dark side
he can do anything he wants to and his
death
almost destroyed the entirety of the
multiverse uh releases his
his falling you know almost a story the
entirety of the multiverse true form
dark side can never really be defeated
thanks for watching guys peace like it
would be
it would kind of be a pretty quick and
boring video
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explained make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob corp if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so